all right we are on location
at the blaze studios here in dallas
texas
and i'm sitting across from mr blaze
glenn beck
aye sir how's it going my man good to
see you thank you for letting us do an
on location shoot i feel
not a problem i know you're here for
about 10 minutes and then you're
i think you're gonna probably be on the
moon and then a stop at the mars
and you know a little bit about
traveling a lot i do
yeah so i'm in between a thousand things
here uh great
yeah it's it's pretty cool uh i wanna
spend a lot of time talking about
this book here addicted to outrage um
but let's just
do everything so right now we're about
two and a half weeks away from this
midterm election
i suspect something completely bananas
over the next two and a half weeks i
mean you can already just see between
between the kavanaugh stuff that we've
been dealing with the general outrage
and all the things you're writing about
here so here we i just said this to a
group of friends the other day
i think at this point a spaceship
could appear okay and and hover over new
york city and
be like huh i mean i don't know what
would surprise me now
well we'd be arguing about the gender
pronouns of the aliens you know i know i
know
it's it's absolutely insane
how everything is everything is upside
down
everything is upside down do you think
do you think we're in a unique time
because that's one of the questions when
i'm out there with peterson often people
say okay it's you know everyone says
we're we've never been more partisan
and we're angrier than ever and all of
these things but does something about
this
seem unique yeah i i'm uh i'm a
glutton for history yes yes and uh it
we have been in perilous times before
i don't think we've hit the civil war uh
confrontations yet
but we are approaching it do you think
we really are because i do
because i'm actually worried about the
amount of people you see this on twitter
all the time people saying oh
civil war is coming you know like
there's like murmur about
what would be the most horrific possible
outcome of all of this
remind me to talk about the window
because i think we have a window right
now
but we have been uh we've been worse
i mean if you look at jefferson and
adams
you know adam's adams was called a
hermaphrodite
by jefferson jefferson jefferson
his campaign
called him a hermaphrodite adams said
back that
if you elect thomas jefferson there will
be
blood in the streets and the heads of
our
children and your daughters will be on
pikes
into every town so we've had rhetoric
like
this before ironically i'd be thrilled
to vote for either one of these guys
if that would be like i'll take either i
don't care heads on pikes that would be
fine but
but it all does go to just in the last
couple weeks you know there was this
hillary clinton line on cnn talking to
christiana christiane amanpour
about how we can't be civil because
these these people meaning the
conservatives or republicans
are so against our values i mean this is
dangerous stuff
here's the difference
we have been in these places before but
we knew our founding documents we
knew who we served or who our god was
and i don't know who our god is now i
mean is it money
is it fame is it anger i don't know what
our god is now
um we knew wait can you let me pause you
there for a sec so when you when you say
that about what the founders believed
now they were also saying separation of
church and state the whole time so
if you were just laying out what they
believed when you say
we knew who our god was um so
george washington they did believe in
the division of
church and state clearly i do too
yeah um that just means if you're an
atheist
you're an atheist we're friends we're
cool let's get along
but if you're a god person you do your
god thing you do your atheist thing
right
do we have what adam smith called moral
sentiment
in common yes capitalism
uh has lost the first volume of adam
smith
the second volume is wealth of nations
the first volume is moral sentiments
and that says look this is an invisible
hand
and the market is powerful and it will
create whatever you want
be careful what you ask for
make sure you are always tempering the
moral sentiment make sure that you're
good decent fair-minded people
we've lost that we're losing it i should
say
and i'm concerned and i
talk about this a bit in the book
i've seen this coming for almost two
decades
and i have been warning against it and
for the very first time i'm at the place
where i'm on the air now saying
this is the time this is the time that i
said would come
yeah and now is the time for you to
remember
who you are um and our outrage is
taking us away from it so as i've looked
at this
for so long i have i have
studied revolutions i have i've studied
giant
movements of chaos i i can tell you
about you know
uh the um i think it was the red
month uh in the 1930s like i can
show you what's happened but there are
three people
in four people in grand movements that
have
gotten it right there was abraham
lincoln
there was martin luther king there was
gandhi
then there's bonhoeffer bonhoeffer do
you know who dietrich bonhoeffer was i
don't think so okay
bonhoeffer lost okay bonhoeffer was
a um a
pastor i think lutheran in germany
he uh was on the air when the fuhrer
declared he was
fewer he was taken his broadcast was cut
and short because he was doing a
broadcast called the fuhrer principle
this is wrong don't go this way
he on kristallnacht the very next
morning he was shopping in those stores
those jewish
stores pacifist
he tried to turn the germans back and
say
stop it stop stop you're going the wrong
way
he couldn't do it he eventually escaped
from
germany was in new york not here very
long because he felt
guilty how can i leave my country when
it's in this much trouble
he went back he realized there's no
there's no reason to stop this guy
maybe violence is the answer he was
involved in
um one of the attempts to kill um hitler
he went to a concentration camp he died
he was executed like five days before
hitler died
here's the thing if you read his
writings
he's gandhi he's jesus he's martin
luther king he's he's he's got it
and i i've read him and read him and
read him how why did he fail
silence in the face of evil is evil
itself
not to stand is to stand he's got it
love one another don't stop playing the
organs so you can hear
the the train going to auschwitz okay
he failed because germans had already
gone over the cliff
they had because of world war one then
the treaty of versailles then the 1920s
they had already lost their
judeo-christian principles they had
lost their center remember if it wasn't
for
england gandhi would have failed
people think of gandhi as starving
himself to get the british to comply
no he starved himself to say
to his own people do not rise up in
anger
they were this close to losing
and he knew it he was appealing to the
sense of decency and
fairness of the british culture
so he knew the people because of their
judeo-christian worldview
would see this oppression and go that's
wrong
if we we have a window and it's closing
if we
give in to our anger our outrage and we
say
you know what i can't take it anymore
we will lose and that window of the
judeo-christian values will close
and then we're done yeah it's so
interesting because one of the themes
that keeps coming up as i'm on this tour
is people keep asking me about this how
much worse is it going to get before
there's some sort of reset
and all of these things and it's like
man i don't want
two months from now or four years from
now to look back at right before the
2018 elections and go boy weren't those
the good old days
because we've gone on on the train to
hell so do you think there's actually no
way to stop it at this point do you
think that no i think there is a way
behind it so
here's here's the scenarios that i'm
looking at
right now if i'm war gaming okay none of
these i know the prediction business
always works out so let's see where you
got here so
if you're wargaming yeah let's look at
the next election
what happens well the democrats probably
gonna win the house
okay they win the house you know they're
going to at least subpoena his tax
records
he's not going to give up tax records
that'll be brought to the supreme court
remember that marker number one that's
day number one day number two
they don't have any place they can go on
impeachment they have to impeach them
even if they don't have anything right
they've already said it they have to do
they have to do it
it'll be the senate that will throw
they'll throw it to the senate that's
where the trial happens
so impeachment just means we're taking
you to court okay
so that's day number two day number
three
uh trump has already filed with the
supreme court saying i'm not
i'm not testifying i'm not turning over
my tax records
i'm not doing this okay well kavanaugh
has already said
he's already seen that that's a
distraction the president shouldn't have
to so
day number three when trump has brought
it to the supreme court
then the house says wait a minute
kavanaugh should
recuse himself we're looking at a year
yeah where uh the three branches of
government
the administration plus the house
and the senate both of them will be
fighting with each other
they'll be fighting with this branch and
they'll be fighting with the supreme
court
when kavanaugh doesn't recuse himself
they will file
articles of impeachment for him and
they're they're leading all of these
ideas already i mean these ideas are
trickling out
this is gonna happen yeah so now you
have the press
the fourth branch already in chaos has
has absolutely no credibility at all
it's deranged and that pushes
what you would call the fifth branch or
the first branch the people
into the streets how do you solve that
right so before we get to the streets
can i give you the one
option that i think maybe saves us from
all that which is that the republicans
win or at least hold in the midterms
thus
finally as long shot as this is finally
the democrats go
okay we've got to drop identity politics
we've got to get away from this
socialist democrat democrat socialist
nonsense there's no evidence that they
would ever look in the mirror if
anything they've only doubled down every
time
yeah but i see that as the only out to
where you're going
so i think if you have if they don't win
the house
if you win the house god forbid if they
win the house and the senate then it's
chaos
but if you win if they win the house the
democrats
that scenario is going to play out in
some form or another
so that just gets worse and worse or
worse i was talking to a friend of mine
just last night about this
and he said you know just exactly what
you said and i
followed it up with what you said show
me the i know there's no evidence
i am spartacus is all of a sudden going
to say
okay i'm not spartacus yeah you know i'm
the
carpenter from you know from nazareth no
wasn't that the danger all along and
this this is directly linked to your
book i mean i remember before the
election i kept saying
and this is when i still considered
myself on the left and and someone that
had basically only voted democrat my
entire life i think the one time i voted
republican was
uh bloomberg's third term in new york
city after he had flipped
like 87 times over something i'm not
even sure if he was republican at that
point
um but that i kept saying before the
election
if you keep calling trump hitler
then no matter what he does and no
matter what reality is
you'll never be able to get yourself out
of that little thing place you've
painted yourself and that's where we are
so you know what's crazy i lived this
i lived this i said
i'm the guy who got in so much trouble
saying i think barack obama may be a
racist
now i immediately corrected it in that
on the spot and said that's not quite
right i now understand i explain it in
the book
i now understand how to express that
i wasn't up on anti-colonialism i
certainly wasn't up on post-modernism
so i'm hearing all these terms that mean
nothing to me
and yet they're always attacking groups
to me and to a lot of people in the
country that's the definition of racism
yeah okay
but i didn't understand the difference
the other part other part of it okay
it's now
social justice okay well social justice
seems wrong to me
that's how i defined it then that was so
divisive
when i said that and i was really at the
time struggling to figure out what is
happening how
who is this guy um and i
got more and more strident uh
and didn't make a lot of friends on the
left
okay yeah it didn't work
it didn't work my base got stronger
my base learned things but my base also
as things went on got more and more
angry as did i
why isn't this working well because you
cannot call
people names and expect them to come
over
we have i just saw a new poll today that
shows
i think it's eight percent of the
american public eight thousand people
interviewed
eight percent of the american public is
the die-hard progressive
radical okay um
the uh the never give up
conservative traditional conservative
is about 29 okay they're both
on the edges 27 29 somewhere in that
area
still on the edges the vast majority
is now being called the exhausted class
and it's the class of people and i'm in
this
guys it doesn't have to be this way i
don't i'm tired of this
i don't i not everybody is a racist not
everybody is a homophobe
stop it stop it the kavanaugh jordan
peterson
got into trouble and i i tweeted he did
tweeted back to him
i think this might be the first time i
disagree but i put i think
because well for people that didn't see
it basically he said
that what would probably be best and he
did this in a tweet which is never the
best way to do it
and he's already he's already had his
media on that and released a correct
nut correction a clarification in a blog
form
uh but basically he said the best
outcome would be that kavanaugh gets
confirmed but then steps down
and what he meant was that wasn't saying
that kavanaugh did do anything or didn't
do anything but if there's any chance
for a little bit of healing
where everyone gets a little egg on
their face but also gets a little bit of
dignity to walk away with
and the country doesn't come apart at
the seams that was what he tried to do
right in a tweet and
in his blog post he's acknowledged that
trying to do that in a tweet
probably not the best thing trying to do
that in a tweet
um where the people who are reading it
are generally
all about politics and tearing each
other apart yeah bad idea that's why i
put
i think because knowing jordan
the little that i do he's a deep
philosophical thinker so my
my feeling was and it turns out it was
right that he's looking at that and
saying
okay in in a normal world in a good
world where we're all really trying to
do the right thing
and if we really were all trying to do
the right thing i agree with him
it would have been the best thing to
have
jordan say or to have kavanaugh say
thank you
thank you now let's bring the country
back together
nominate somebody else and let's go
through it but the other side would have
gone through
exactly the same thing you would have
rewarded them in the end because they
got it
because we're talking about the machines
of destruction
so reality doesn't play a role at some
point
this 70 percent of america is
going to stand up and say shut up
both of you are you shocked how many
people in that 70
are just afraid to do that because when
we do these meet and greets after the
the peterson event i think the number
one question i get
asked is what can i do i'm afraid to
speak
and i cannot i mean i see this you know
from people that i'm
sitting this close to and i see this
look in their eyes of fear
and it's like i don't think i'm that
brave i don't know why i'm doing this i
don't i'm just doing it i can't explain
it
but i don't wake up every morning and
i'm like what am i going to do today to
fight google and fight the political
powers
i'm just like i'm just doing what i
think is right that's it
that so that goes to i brought my family
2011 to auschwitz
and i did it again because i see
over the horizon i think and
we stood outside of the gates and
um we had a prayer and then i said
okay we are here
because we have to look at the
ugliest thing man has done and we have
to decide
who we are who we're going to be
because if you weren't prepared and i
don't mean
prepare for that kind of stuff i mean
really know
who you are you will not stand
when the jack-booted thugs come down the
street you have to
know who you are and what you believe so
i had them read
a story of the righteous of the nation
they could pick anyone who saved jews
and really try to get into their head i
lined up in
a just a family kind of conversation
with this
sweet woman she just died i think last
week she's 90 years old
she was a christian she was 16 years old
when she saved
the first jew her whole family did it
it was remarkable um
and we we talked about it
two things i learned on that trip one
as we were leaving i said to her look
i have a responsibility that's different
than most because i speak to so many
people
and i said i believe that people have
that tree of righteousness in them i
think they have that goodness
they want to do the right thing how do i
water it
she told me something so profound it's
so
game changing she she looked at me
so puzzled and she said you
misunderstand
the righteous didn't suddenly become
righteous
they just refuse to go over the cliff
with the rest of humanity
all you have to do is remember what
you've always believed was true
and then just stand and just go no you
guys are crazy
you don't have to be a hero you're not a
hero she was looking at me she wouldn't
let me film her
she only let me take one picture of her
she wanted
nothing because she's like i'm not a
hero i just remembered what was right
that's remarkable do you think that the
default position of humanity
is to cower that in that in these
moments it seems like it's a lot
easier to cower right i mean
even now like that's the thing when
people say this to me about
how do i get brave or whatever it's like
we live in the freest place
in the history of the world bravery and
if you're if you're afraid now imagine
the second that thing gets turned a
little bit
how afraid you're going to be so it
seems like like fear
and and i'm sure there's a psychological
component to this that fear does
something in the brain that may be
bravery or or maybe it really is about
just knowing
what you are and what you're making let
me tell you two stories um
uh first fear shuts
your brain down okay it shuts reason
down
you're in fight or flight and that's a
good thing
because you don't want to be going well
i don't know should i hit him a little
harder
you're just swinging so fear and anger
really bad and that's why we're addicted
outrage
we will swing you got to get shake that
or you won't think
it's biological
two stories um the other person we met
with
in poland was the chief rabbi
and he said i think it was seven
thousand there were seven thousand
people that stood
and i was i mean when have you been to
auschwitz no i haven't
when you go there's churches i mean a
block away
yeah there are houses everywhere and
they're old they were there
and i left there and i was enraged i
remember
crying and and looking at the houses and
screaming in my head where the hell were
you
where were you
i meet with him and i said how
out of all the millions of people and he
said
you're thinking that's a small number
you said that's an incredible number of
people
people you're in a scary movie
you look away when something like this
is coming
it is human nature to look away
or to dismiss and you it's
it's it's um we have this gift of fear
that warns us but we use
logic and sometimes we use it just to
protect ourselves
because dave i don't think people are
afraid
of standing i think they're afraid of
knowing the truth
you look at the people who stand the
people who stand
are the ones who are going you know i
learned something new
i learned something it's changed me
they're not standing you're not standing
because you're brave and i'm going to
take a stand
you're saying wait a minute i just
scales fell off my eyes i just learned
something
when you are inquisitive when you are
based in wait a minute i i really want
to know
you have already prepared to yeah but
do you really you and i i know you know
this
i think we've talked about it i went
through it and you went through it
you do come to a point to where you're
saying
if i take another step everything in my
life could change
my friends might change they might look
at me differently
and you take that step and say yeah i
want to know the truth
that's where people fail they
if you can't take that leap
and that's why i really think you're
seeing people like you
you're seeing the inquisitive because
that's in their nature to question
question wait a minute that doesn't make
sense that doesn't make sense
and if you're like that you most likely
have already passed that line of
uncomfortability
because you've had things you realized
you went oh crap
okay well i guess i don't believe that
anymore
yeah and i just don't know how i could
wake up and
put stuff in my hair and look in the
mirror and go that's why i just don't
know how i could do it but i know some
people do it and then i get i think this
is what jordan would describe as sort of
the slow road to hell
you will just diminish yourself and
diminish yourself every every day of
your life until the end
just you have to stop looking
you have to turn around because it will
always
present you with the option oh you saw
it
you looked out and you saw them just
lining up a family of jews shooting them
okay now what do you do once you
see it it presents you with the choice
do i go back to sleep or do i stand
so i know every you know it's very easy
to always be like okay both sides are
going crazy they're equally horrible and
all of those
things like that's sort of like the easy
the easy way of doing it i'm not saying
that's
that's what you're doing here but that's
sort of the easy way to do it and we all
fall in that trap sometimes right
because
just for brevity's sake sometimes it's
easier to say that but it seems to me
that for all the people that
that absolutely despise trump that
that hate everything about the right the
right basically has been in power for
the last two years
there's a lot of good things happening
in the country related to economics
and the fact that we're not entering
foreign wars and there's some
interesting things happening
with north korea and a series of other
things and the state
has not used its power to silence anyone
what i fear and this is why i don't
think it's an even oh both sides are
crazy thing
is that the left is about state power
and what i fear is they've said well
half of the country is nazis we cannot
be civil with them because they're
coming to get us
and if these people took power well now
we have everything that you just laid
out because they don't mind using the
apparatus of the state right to
accomplish their goals and i'm not
saying republicans are always right
about this stuff and they
they screw up all the little government
things that they should care about and
all of that
the left has become everything they said
the tea party was
okay that we weren't we weren't um they
have become
violent they have become unreasonable
they want to silence people and they
will silence people that's why you're
seeing people start
begin to stand up and say ha-ha
however it's one of my fears with donald
trump and the great thing is he says a
lot
and most of it never happens you know
what i mean my fear
is he has said you know maybe we should
look into the license of these companies
you know
i don't think he means it but you signal
that to people
on the right or the left you're you're
basically saying yeah that's on the
that's on the field
of play it's not on the field of play um
although there's an interesting
libertarian argument whether the
government should be giving licensing
no no i don't think they should have
license at all right right i don't i
certainly don't want
the government to say you know what
you've been a little harsh so i'm gonna
look into your life
no right not at all get him out of that
here's the
here's the thing that people aren't
thinking about government
is about to become
unless it marries into it
pretty inconsequential because it will
never be able to keep
up with technology so is that the saving
grace here
no not not that i was going to give
google a lot of
the left is concentrating their power in
silicon valley and
that's where you can really silence
people the guy who wrote
um ibm and the holocaust
gosh i can't remember his name brilliant
guy
well thought out um we were talking
and um
talking about how the germans how they
silence people and how they
they cordon people off and then just get
smaller and smaller groups
and then they eventually put you behind
a wall in a ghetto
well they would build the wall higher
and higher so people couldn't hear or
see isn't that what google and facebook
are doing we're building digital ghettos
we
have the ability now you can speak all
you
want dave but i'm changing the algorithm
and you're not going to be heard i mean
you look at what the deal with facebook
was
i promote them i give them
my 10 million listeners and i say
hey you can find me at facebook let's
communicate
then they take those listeners that said
i
want to hear from him and then they
change the algorithm
and i can't communicate to my own people
yeah and we know this is happening
across the board you probably saw my
insane tweet thread about all of i just
started retweeting all of these people
real people not russian bots and avatars
i was taking purposely real people with
real names with real pictures
and they're all saying they're
unsubscribed there were people who pay
it wasn't just the free people it was
the people who pay for youtube red or
youtube tv
still getting unsubscribed and it's like
what did we all
sign up for here but dare i do you like
the biblical analogies i'll do one here
there was david verse goliath and i
think dave can take down google
this dave i think there's a chance i
mean i think that story i'm being
slightly hyperbolic obviously but i
think that these things have become
so big i mean this i guess is what the
essence of the story was right
that this goliath this google has become
so big that it will crumble
under its own under the weight of its
own crap basically that there will be
enough people
inside the broken machine that will wake
up
that i hope that individuals basically i
i hope
all you got is hope right yeah and
you're you're three to five years away
from it being a cage
i mean their behavior with china which i
outline in the book
is pretty horrific um what china what
the road china is going down
is terrifying and google is
right there with them um and that is
evil
that is evil they say don't be evil well
that is the definition of it
um and if they just slowly
you know the guy who closes the door on
the gas chamber
was most likely a guy that was fixing
trucks
before the war in a normal guy you don't
suddenly become
evil you slowly move into it
especially if you're surrounded by a
group of people that are all
absolutely convinced that they are right
and the other voice is wrong and
therefore we just have to filter them
out
with a.i and the way they are gobbling
it's really disturbing and the
problem is going to happen you know
we're going to start hitting
um massive job loss probably 2020
2021 22. that's when you're going to
really start to feel the effects of
of um when that happens
if you look at history and we know it
all the politicians now are saying i'm
going to get those jobs back from china
you're not because they're leaving china
because they're getting too expensive in
china
so you're not getting those jobs back
and especially because
ai and robotics are growing
we'll have 30 percent unemployment by
2030
30 percent permanent unemployment
so you look at this what do politicians
always do
they got to find a bad guy well right
now it's
china but as soon as people realize that
wait a minute it's silicon valley that's
taking my jobs
the politician then says it's
those people those people that are
building the robots
unless those people also see over the
horizon
and become buddy buddy with their
friends in washington
and they work together then you
have a surveillance state
that i don't think we ever get out of